the fact that the dual motor um has such
a significant performance improvement in
the car it really improves every element
of it from
obviously handling because it's
all-wheel drive um but even in the
handling is better than any other
all-wheel drive because we're able to
digitally transfer the torque from front
to rear and we're able to increase the
top speed of the car increase the
acceleration of the car and actually the
dual motors also provide redundancies
like having a twin engine plane so even
if one of the motors conks out for any
reason you can actually just drive on
the front one or the rear one oh really
okay so that's an added safety feature
there yeah yeah exactly so you save
change improvement and then the range
actually increases because um as you
were talking about earlier you can map
the efficiency codes of both motor
motors and
the efficiency improvements with the
motors overwhelm the the weight increase
but
how is this going to though burnish the
image of tesla motors as being
eventually a car company that's for the
masses when you're actually introducing
a car that's going to be more expensive
yeah the this this is not uh this
particular event is really about
showcasing what electric cars are
capable of okay um
and and showing that an electric car can
be the highest performance car in the
world in fact
the
performance version of the the dual
motor
has an acceleration 060 time equivalent
to one of the best supercars ever which
is mclaren f1 so it goes 0-60 in 3.2
seconds which will get pretty close to
that although we've got four people in
the car plus a lot of camera equipment
um should we try that sure okay all
right let's try it guys are you ready
braces are you guys praised
all right here we go all right
all right
whoa
just see that person step aside
wow what did you think when you first
experienced this
sorry guys
yes okay okay
what did you think so it's not followed
up high right now okay touching anything
no hands no feet nothing
what technology is in here
it's a it's a combination of
radar
camera with image recognition and
ultrasonic sensors that's integrated
with our maps and real-time traffic
and it's really what enables autopilot
capabilities the synthesis of all those
four systems okay
so when you were just accelerating back
there right like let's say and you know
you saw that
it break by itself by the way yeah i saw
i said and i've seen that a few times so
we saw that person sort of like jump
jump aside right when when when he saw
you coming so let's say you were
accelerating that quickly and an object
flew in your way what would happen then
if you were on autopilot would it
immediately break on its own
um yeah it it if it detected that there
was something that was going to hit the
car it would do its best to mitigate the
impact velocity okay so it would it
would break
now it's always possible i mean you can
in business scenario where if you're
going you know 60 miles down the road
and something leaps in front of you
there's no there's nothing nothing yeah
nothing okay under any circumstances um
so it you know it can't do impossible
things but it can massively improve the
safety of where someone that's the
driver doesn't notice that there's a
pedestrian about to cross the road or
that there's a car that's come to a stop
in front of them
so in driver distraction situations it
could really be a lifesaver